el viaje de bolodini zelensky a
Washington se saldó con un millonario
paquete de ayuda militar para Ucrania y
no hay duda de Cuál es la pieza central
[Aplausos]
de casi dos mil millones de dólares y el
elemento más fuerte de este paquete es
el sistema patreon reforzará
significativamente nuestra defensa aérea
es un paso importante en la creación de
un escudo aéreo eficaz para Ucrania
el sistema de misiles tierra aire ha
sido fabricado desde 1976 por el grupo
armamentístico estadounidense saltó a la
fama durante la Guerra del Golfo de 1991
y ha sido un equipo básico para el
ejército estadounidense y muchos de sus
aliados Ucrania recibirá una batería
contiene 4 misiles pack 2 como un
alcance de 160 kilómetros o 16 misiles
pack 3 con un alcance de 40 kilómetros
kiev que la adquisición del sistema
Patriot cambie las reglas del juego en
la guerra con Rusia permitiéndole
rastrear y derribar mejor los misiles
balísticos pero una sola batería tendrá
un efecto limitado
los sistemas que ya tienen los nasán los
anti los Iris no pueden funcionar
realmente bien para eso están los
Patriots y francamente si el objetivo es
el VIP ni Pro o hard un sistema
desplegado alrededor de kiev no va a
alcanzar esos objetivos no van a acertar
esos misiles necesitarán muchos más
Patriots
hasta que Ucrania no aumente su
capacidad con los patreon es poco
probable que los nuevos misiles tengan
un efecto decisivo en la guerra pero sí
una mayor capacidad para repeler los
ataques cierto alivio para la población
de kiev que sufre frecuentes bombardeos